brightly colored eggs and bunnies at
this Berlin Easter market you can find
them in all shapes and sizes here in
Germany they're typical symbols of the
Easter holiday but what are their
origins the advertising industry because
all the little bunnies are born in
spring aren't they I really don't know
no kidding
maybe because of spring but the next
question is what - eggs have to do with
it
we've heard through photography and
there's more than one answer to that
question eggs are eaten at Easter in
many countries one explanation comes
from the Middle Ages this Pentagon site
there was a very old theory which is
also well documented that farmers
collected eggs on Maundy Thursday and
then used them to pay the rent on their
land tins and vitek he gave him golden
eggs and the Easter rabbit were first
mentioned in writing three hundred
thirty years ago and a work by German
doctor Georg von flunking out the rabbit
symbolizes fertility spring and new
beginnings the eggs the Easter Bunny
brings celebrate the end of 40 days of
fasting during Lent you couldna souls
investment in the fussin site you could
say that during Lent people didn't think
so much about the rabbits fertility and
vitality and it's the same with the eggs
during Lent they were eaten in large
amounts instead people collected things
for later so it's also a feast day
people eat again enjoy life again and
use eggs to symbolize renewed life thus
no you leave
the symbols aren't just decorative
they're also tasty in Germany it's
customary for the Easter Bunny to hide
eggs and children to hunt for them on
Easter Sunday
the Sedna to offer them of course that
also is a religious and spiritual
dimension we search for something an
insight of the resurrection there off a
steel so this year the Easter Bunny will
again bring millions of children
colorful eggs and chocolate no matter
what the customs origins are the main
thing is they taste delicious